j'accueille maintenant chantal goya
bonsoir il m me chantal plus envie de
baiser chantal pour l'interview de vie
c'est le travail d'avants après et on
board et le wii bien sûr rémunérateurs
hélas sérieux surtout que chantal est la
double promo tout bon soir ou pas les
attroupements triple promo oui mais j'en
connais deux mois il ya des gens qui
font un double album
moi j'ai le vif qui s'appelle la niaque
est une autobiographie
et puis le cd et le dvd et le palais des
congrès annuel à lui entendu bah oui
bien sûr mais oui c'est sûr ils n'ont
dit si on faisait des coulisses veut
céder le série c'est un best-of et ses
dessins des stocks est égal devant le
parquet de munich a faim
dix réclament alors sonné
tu peux deviner ce qu'il a envie de
manger rien que ça c'est super pour moi
c'est du poisson ce qu'ils réclament on
le voyait faire mais alors que le cd
donc c'est un best of et le dvd
c'est le spectacle mystérieux voyage de
marie rose
alors on va on va commencer par le
best-of voilà vous voulez écouter les
chansons de chantal goya dj
du son bac qu'elle
chance devant lui n'ont pas jeté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j
oui
les deux ensemble et nous prenons
chandelle
chauffer
m
non
il a refusé coup oui
voilà c'est passé
quoi là
au bout
cela
oh
ton ami
ok
ouais
jeudi
merci
je pense que
d
[Musique]
rapide
non
oui
[Musique]
ces temps ci
quand
les filles
[Musique]
oui
chantal goya
le vestiaire
[Applaudissements]
on se croirait au queen ouais alors
dans ce petit coffret qu'est-ce qui a le
rang on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
non on me dit qu'il faut tout refaire
chantal goya bonsoir
non il ya une caméra sur alain chabat si
vous pouvez me fier d'aller casser
j'offre ça noël c'est à faire à ta
famille parce que bien sûr parfois tu
déconne mais parfois ça tapait guignols
de la traite et on va se faire vacciner
et didier
longchamp
pas
ah oui
il ya longtemps
[Applaudissements]
promener dans la rue
est ce que les enfants seront toujours
vers vous naturellement bon c'est les
grands teams embrasse l'autre jour j'ai
un agent de police qui m'a arrêté qu'il
a dit alors je dis ça y est je dis
qu'est-ce que j'ai encore fait à la
bourse a commencé et m'a dit non non je
rêvais demander qu'une chose c'est parce
que moi je sais tellement aimé petit
quand j'avais 3 ans est ce que pour lui
chanter le lapin moi j'ai ouvert la
fenêtre j'ai fait ce matin un lapin est
ce que vous le chantez à ma femme avec
le portable
c'est un niveau bas j'ai chanté dans le
portable à être écouté j'ai à chaque
fois que je serai là je vous demanderais
parce que je vous aime on s'est tous les
grands ouais si les petits les petits
bouts et les tp team connaissent moi
c'est leur maman et leur papa parce que
ces générations 1980 à son beau diable
quand on les petits vous demande comment
on fait des enfants vous répondez quoi
chagall a dit c'est bien
non mais le sait chantal qu'il ya des
enfants des jo
si un petit nord c'est un petit de 8 ans
vous demande comment on fait des enfants
vous dit pas avec la [ __ ] j'imagine dans
un chou avec la ville mais dans un arrêt
pour lui tant l'art vous dites quoi
chanter vous êtes judicata tu es petit à
petit fiancée que tu adores et puis
c'est compliqué ce que vous me demandez
là bas non qu'elles consentent à halle
alors non pas bien qu'ayant ils ont des
parents c'est leurs parents qui
n'auraient ce nom mais les parents son
institut de faire leur boulot de parents
vous savez bien ils ont tous démissionné
les parents depuis la 67e réellement
avec une perte ou une partie de notre
corps la calquer un voilà voilà voilà
tout simplement écrit c'est très
agréable qui ça se passe très bien voilà
football en ce sens pas bien c'est pas
une belle affiche pour le palais des
congrès chansons plus quand les enfants
des demandes quand les enfants vous
demande pourquoi c'est pas bien la
drogue vous dites quoi ah ben moi je
sais que c'est de la merde
non non vous n'avez pas raison parce
qu'en dix ans a ému les gens n'ont pas
ou croirez vous allez en prendre quand
même donc vos tongs c'est de la merde on
a du mal à dire à croire que c'est de la
mer et que tout le monde en problème
d'un à ce prix là oui j'ai surtout à 70
euros le gramme quoi il ya cinq ans
j'avais prévu d'emmener mon pote je suis
même pas une cigarette avec les jeunes
mais plus jamais d'alcool est là qu en
mettant un petit enfant vous dis maman
pourquoi vous du projet de jj tout dur
vous dites quoi maintenant vous
est-ce que bécassine même lapine c'est
la question que beaucoup de gens se
posent chez eux
vraiment j'ai tellement eu quelques noms
et bien alors ça donc c'était le dvd le
cd laurent maintenant on va passer au
livre s'appelle la niaque 1 chez jacques
marie laffont éditeur
alors là on comprend mieux le personnage
de chantal goya votre côté un peu
enfants attardés
parce que finalement enlève enfants on
attendait certainement chantal je vais
vous dire laissez moi finir parce
qu'après il y avait après il y avait une
explication c'était pas une norme el
fihri je te rappelle que chantal a peur
elle a le trac il faut l'aider mais oui
mais c'est pas tu écoutes guerre et
quizz ou alors ils vivent dans les
favelas et bien la passion
non
la conserver
que
ah la la
etc
non
par le même temps il n'y a pas de poster
de tuer tout ce que comprend mieux le
personnage de chantal goya un peu
enfants attardés
quand on sait que vous avez eu une prime
enfance en indochine à l'époque
coloniale c'est ce qu'on apprend en
lisant le livre et que vous avez gardé
de cette époque des souvenirs magiques
période très heureuse près de saigon les
vacances dans les montagnes à dalat au
cambodge etc
donc voilà ce que je voulais dire et le
perdre le père de chantal diriger une
plantation d'hévéa de quarante mille
hectares il a été obligé de fuir le pays
ça a été l'épisode vous êtes retrouvés à
en métropole après un voyage
épouvantable
et là vous vous retrouvez à paris dans
un minuscule appartement de 50 ans avec
des grands-parents insupportable là et
vous recréez votre enfance en indochine
voilà ce que je voulais dire c'est à
dire que c'est très gentil
voilà voilà c'est vrai vous avez toute
votre vie et cherchait à retrouver cette
prime enfance indochinois c'est vraiment
avec avec les pousse-pousse avec les
grands à regarder enfin la doshisha
savez j'avais une chinoise qui
s'occupait de moi qui tu n'as sa maxi
est une femme sacrée qu'a dû me donner
quelque chose d'important parce que mes
frères et soeurs on non pas un petit peu
cette espèce de tenues ce que j'ai et je
traverse toutes les difficultés toujours
avec optimisme la niaque la niaque
non mais c'est vrai que déjà tout petit
j'ai traversé des difficultés sans même
me rendre compte par exemple quand il y
avait les japonais qui étaient au pied
de la maison qu'ils voulaient assassiner
qui ont assassiné beaucoup de français
moi j'étais caché dans un dans un sous
ali je crois que mon frère était dans un
placard et moi évidemment quand maman
regarde les attraits d'aller voler ce
qui se passait parce que les
vietnamiennes nous avait beaucoup et
nous et des mois j'ai traversé la maison
j'ai descendu l'escalier j'ai demandé à
l'armée ne lasse et mon lacet de
chaussure
voilà et alors ils ont bas et son bep
saison assez mon lacet de chaussure et
puis son parti et la maison et la
famille était sauvé voilà alors deuxième
choc de votre vie votre rencontre avec
les beatles
ouais voilà avec quoi à l'époque vous
sortez avec le fils du duc et la
duchesse de bedford un cul de planter
il ne savait même pas qui il est
non parce que nous on aller dans des
soirées ou ajinça à paris l'après midi
c'était soirée d'après midi moi je sais
on posait pas de question qu'est ce que
fait ton père ta mère et quand j'étais à
londres et que j'étais au père gilles
malige 100 m haies chez mes parents en
week-end ou en vacances ou déjà mais je
ne sais plus déjeuner alors il est venu
me suis rhabillé présenter tout mais
tablier et autres et puis je sais pas où
j'étais tombé je n'en croyais pas mes
yeux et ils m'ont dit à déjeuner y aura
des gens importants qui viendront et
dans la grande salle à sergeac tertio
judy une fois pour toutes la charrette
avec les frères salah est mort sur le
coup pas mental système association des
stars les frères jamais mort ils sont
vivants et si tu le sais je le coupe au
monde que la torre 10e finale
si mes personnages je sais qu'il est
coupée au montage
les élèves donc j'ai bon espoir je le
coupe aussi c'est vrai maternité ray
colette renard a non pas de pascal
sevran dans le bartos aussi les réveils
avaient donc quatre personnages qui sont
arrivés et là j'ai halluciné c'était
l'ebita les buteurs des jeunes et voilà
c'est lé plus impressionné que riri fifi
et loulou ils n'étaient que trois tous
trois ont ils chanté à l'époque que she
loves you s'est depuis la mi juillet y
est enfin c'était c'était uniquement
pour moi je n'ai pas et alors le choc
suivant ça a été votre rencontre avec
jean jacques debout là ça a été la
valeur sai thein c'est à dire que à
peine il vous a vus il vous dit j'ai
l'impression de vous connaître depuis
toujours on se mariera on aura deux
enfants vous serez célèbre à 30 ans et
vous chanterez à l'opéra en attendant on
va baiser la rage
incroyable ouais alors je lui ai dit bon
je vais bien là on se mariera peut-être
chanter certainement pas parce qu'il ya
je suis j'ai pas vraiment une voix d'un
alors quand à l'opéra si j'étais maria
callas ça serait et avoir deux enfants
bon ça peut être possible
et ben voilà il est tout ce qui est
arrivé est arrivé quand même il vous
propose de le suivre antilles parce
qu'il allait participer à la rose board
et que c'est génial chanson qui
s'appelle audois se sont croisés et ils
vous oubliez à paris vous aux régions et
méfier un mec qui vous fait ça attire un
mec vous le rencontrez et vous promet de
vous épousez de faire deux enfants ils
vous invitent à antibes et par sens vous
sur l'a10 vous servir de leçon je crois
vous ayez persévérer au delà de ça parce
que moi c'est moi c'est tout m'intéresse
quant au blé un mois quand elle ne le
dit ça c'est qu'il a vraiment quelque
chose qui m'intéresse c'est que je peux
aller plus loin ah bon et s'il me dit
d'aller bien ça y est j'ai oublié à
paris ça vous a pas servi par sa laïcité
gratitude on est obligé d'y aller avec
quelqu'un d'autre finale mais comme chip
ben non parce que je me dis que j'avais
fait un gros mensonge à mes parents je
leur avais dit que je parte un week-end
j'ai une copine donc mon père m'a dit je
rêve ouakam est ce que tu as dans ton
sac alors j'ai montré à l'inpi nice et
après je peux plus rentrer parce que
j'avais non je pouvais pas j'ai dit il
faut que j'y aille et puis je tenais et
la gagner alors il avait arraché le
chèque au maire y avait un chèque de dix
mille francs et qu'est ce qu'il a fait
la maison il fait toujours ça ben voilà
avec des militants une fois il a acheté
un bateau avec un chèque de 200 francs
il avait rajouté 3 0 c'est vrai ou pas
mais la maison chaque fois je ne les
sens pas quoi ils allaient au salon
nautique
bon je peux même pas attention moi je
reviens ce soir à jean minuit et je vois
dans mon salon tabarly et petitpas r il
petit pas bons ils étaient tous là
autour d'un grand enfin d'un énorme plan
de bateaux jeudi qui souligne tout ça il
ya ba oui juste annoncé une bonne
nouvelle ça y est j'ai acheté un très
beau bateau les stein qui est qui avait
été construit par john alden jeudi mais
comme on va faire il dit bah oui non
mais on s'arrangera et où aulas j'ai
appelé les ateliers de la trinité
c'était pas là j'ai appelé tous les
chantiers de de rolande et c'était là et
là j'étais prendre un très gentil
chercher mon chèque et puis le bateau
chez zéro donc à 19 ans vous installer
avec lui et au bout d'un moment vous
avez envie de faire du journalisme vous
allez voir daniel filipacchi en disant
je veux travailler dans la presse et lui
vous propose de chanter des chansons de
jean jacques debout et qu'est ce que je
chante c'est bien bernard le plus
sénardes de l'avant et danielle lamy sur
salut les copains et puis voilà voilà
j'étais affolée et là alors pire que
tout vous tourné avec jean luc godard
qui vous demande de vous déshabiller
c'est pour masculin féminin
et vous refusez de vous mettre toute nue
oui pourquoi vous avez d'abord j'étais
enceinte de mon fils et je voulais pas
le dire
bon ça commençait bien et on n'était pas
marié ouais j'ai su vraiment des j'étais
enceinte de trois mois et j'ai dit à
marlène comment je peux faire marlène
jobert comment je peux faire je veux pas
d'abord je vais pas me [ __ ] à poil
samat je veux pas aimé du tout inquiète
pas tu vas te cacher sous le lavabo et
moi je vais passer une fois et de fage
fait passer en vente ont des gestes à
toi et moi je passais à ma façon j'étais
ok moi je t'ai planqué sous lavabo puis
godard a dit mais c'est bizarre on
dirait la même silhouette qui basse il a
ouvert la porte il m'a dit mais dis donc
tu te fiches de moi qu'est ce que tu
fais là dessous je dis bah moi je vais
pas tourner à poil
alors je lui dit tu seras jamais une
vedette jeudi je m'en fous la seule
vedette que je connais c'est ma machine
à laver alors du coup je bonne dame des
collines
[Applaudissements]
mais voilà non mais il ya aussi la même
chose en quand j'étais en allemagne je
vais faire un très grand film
et là je vais tourner avec un effet un
vrai baiser avec un garçon j'arrivais
vont arriver à battante et pas mike
brant du tout une horreur je récupère
alors j'ai dit j'espère que ce n'est pas
celui-là et c'était évidemment celui là
est belle baiser c'est comme ça ou alors
on m'a dit bon vous virer terminé plus
de films en ça vous aimez pas vous
balader à poil en moi c'est des garçons
comme ça se fait parce que je réserve ça
jean jacques
alors après bon mais c'est l'époque des
succès vous inventez avec jean jacques
debout le music hall pour enfants c'est
vous qui avait inventé ça oui à tout ça
sera coupée au montage à quel âge est à
braiser pour la première fois non
maintenant
mais on va voir
alors le vendredi 13 décembre 1985
ça porte malheur déjà patrick sabatier
vous reçoit dans le jeu de la vérité
vous appellerez cette émission un
meurtre en direct et ce n'est que huit
ans plus tard que vous pouvez regarder
la cassette de l'émission et vous dites
j'ai vu une folle qui parle moi d'abord
j'avais j'avais pas voulu la faire ce
que j'étais en plein spectacle freestyle
voyage à marie rose que vous avez vu et
moi j'avais dit ça sert à rien puisque
c'est tellement archi complet je ne me
vois pas dans une émission où des
adultes vont parler donc ils m'ont dit
non ce sont des enfants qui vont venir
vous parler
ouais à ce moment là j'ai douté un peu
et jean jacques m'a dit il n'est même
pas question
thierry le luron qui était l'âme a dit
chantal ils vont te alors te planter ça
va être l'horreur et j'ai dit ok jaffe
plus donc j'ai appelé gilles on la fait
plus et l'avant veille
le réalisateur m'a dit écoute au nom de
notre amitié tu devrais quand même la
faire ce sera magnifique aura des belles
choses
on va voir jean jacques ne le voyais pas
jean-jacques il ne veut pas finalement
tout on a tellement c'est moi qui est
qui suis allé au charbon en fin de
compte
alors j'ai joué mon spectacle et la
veille jean jacques m'a dit tu vois
c'est bien là tout les unes de journaux
mais je peux te dire qu à 21h40 il y
aura plus de chantal doyon
oui tu va au casse-pipe tu vas au casse
pipe et je veux centre avec ma robe rose
de marie rose devant un dans mon décor
avec l'arbre la forêt et tout ayant joué
l'après-midi à 8h30 le même public
devant moi de 12000 personnes et pas une
question d'enfants et moi chaque fois
j'étais je prenais tout au troisième
degré alors quand est-ce qu'on marchait
l'alpa cedar chirurgie à la chirurgie
esthétique avec votre tronche donc c'est
pas grave on verra un jour et puis toute
manière à ce que s'est passé chanteur
hélas oui voilà ce qui s'est passé c'est
que c'est qu'en fait vous croyez vous
adresser aux enfants en leur faisant des
grimaces en disant je vais même plaisant
non tu vas faire des grimaces et le
réalisateur rémy grand bac lui il montre
pas les raconte ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'ils ont eu l'idée de mettre une
fausse institutrice c'est elle qui a
tout déclenché ses parents avant je m'en
sortais très bien ça c'est bien
et cette fausse institutrice quand je
vais demander de quelle classe vous êtes
elle n'a jamais pu me le dire c'était
gibbons alors à les fossés les billets
c'est finish dans un traquenard
alors là maintenant j'ai dit à sa bête
j'ai dit à cette femme bah écoutez vous
m'aimez pas changer de chaîne j'allais
pas dire madame vous êtes je suis une
conne et je vous remercie
c'est pas possible devant plus tout mon
public que j'aime pas d'hier soir a
besoin des mêmes pas question alors j'ai
dit bon ben je pose mon micro j'ai dit à
patrick moi je suis désolé il ya simone
signoret sur l'a2 c'est beaucoup mieux
que chantal goya je m'adresse à mon
public qui sont les enfants et je
chantais lapin et là j'ai posé mon micro
g il y avait tous ces gosses devant moi
qu'on ne montrait jamais voilà et que tu
es mort hier chez lui il a cru que
sterbik vous faisant évidemment parce
que dans la panique ginestet attaques de
panique de terroriser et je me suis
réfugié dans le monde de l'enfance parce
que j'étais marié roswell et l'image
elle a été changée et moi j'ai vu quand
je suis sorti de là j'ai toujours pas
compris à la fin d'émission parce que
tout le monde était dans la salle a crié
chantal chantal et quand je suis sorti
que j'ai vu là la haie d'honneur de tous
mes techniciens qui était pratiquement
en larmes
vous êtes arrivé dans la régie et là
vous vous tombez sur jean jacques debout
ivre mort déjà qu'ils avaient tout
compris et jean-jacques y vivait mal
tout ça il avait il avait vu la descente
east c'était quelqu'un qui avait tout
compris bien avant tout le monde
et étant donné qu'il est quand même la
personne qui même le plus et qui était
proche de moi il était malheureux et
finalement on a mis 100 personnes au
chômage et c'est pour ça que moi comme
je suis sam a pas cassé moi parce que
moi j'ai été vrai vis-à-vis de mon
public
quand j'ai fait la pac j'ai dit changer
de chèques changer de chaîne dans les
bars chantal goya c'est que vous m'aimez
pas c'était pour sauver tout le public
des petits qui est proche d'eux vous
pensez une véritable volonté de nuire
derrière cette histoire
attendez mais pourquoi tant recherché
vous dire pour quelle raison patrick
sabatier avait mes grands bacs heureux
envie de vous
rires moi je pense que fin j'ai pas
encore la réponse exacte mais je pense
que il y avait de grandes jalousie qui
circulait dans fin les gens étaient
assez jaloux succès et il ya des gens
qui m'a d'auray et des gens qui m'aimait
pas c'est normal
aujourd'hui tout est bien qui finit bien
car tu es culte non mais je vous dirais
que j'ai tué
une star pour les gosses du véhicule
pour les adultes est tué hyper populaire
quand même bien tu as envie de faire un
duo toi tu as des inégalités chantal non
merde
[Applaudissements]
je vous dis oui série je vais vous dire
ça devait m'arriver cette histoire ouais
et moi je vais très bien prise parce que
je me suis dit 'c'est peut-être très
triste tout ce qui vient de m'arriver
messas grand bonheur pour moi de
retrouver mes petits enfants ma famille
femmes et enfants qui était que je
voyais pas beaucoup ma famille mes amis
et d'être auprès du public qui me
réconfortait tous les jours dit moi vous
lui diriez quoi aujourd'hui à patrick
sabatier s'il était habité vivant qui
m'a présente sa maîtresse d'école
ah oui j'ai jamais vu ah oui c'est
qu'elles existent mais qu'elle n'est pas
si tutrice ça je le sais aussi que
c'était quelqu'un qui était payée par la
production
si vous toujours demandé comment ça se
fait que la journaliste n'a pas été plus
loin dans cette histoire et n'a pas été
voir qui était cette femme qui peut être
très malheureuse dans son coin parce
qu'elle en a pris plein la tronche aussi
moins autant que moi hein parce qu'elle
n'est pas si tutrice aujourd'hui tout va
bien mais le lendemain des missions tout
alléger sur vous fait aujourd'hui une
émission comme le jeu de la vérité pas
on craque et plus on va voir un regard
des mois vous pensez pas que votre
spectacle est nul à chier chantal goya
non j'adore mon spectacle j'aurais
jusqu'au bout non mais j'adore mon
spectacle j'aurais jusqu'au bout marco
ne pensais pas que vous avez tissé les
enfants mais non je n'habite pas ou si
c'est votre choix vous pensez pas qu à
votre âge il faudrait les laisser
tranquilles les formes alors ça alors ça
n'y a pas d'âge pour faire rêver
maintenant si sûr vous êtes endurci
c'est bien ben je me suis plus qu'on
durcisse et que j'ai gardé ma
sensibilité mais j'ai un bon parent
avant devant ouais alors il ya un truc
extraordinaire dans le bouquin je trouve
c'est que vous fermez les yeux sur les
aventures de jean jacques debout sur
vous vous dites que vous l'avez jamais
trompé non jamais jamais parce que non
jamais mais jamais eu envie mais non
mais non parce que 1er mai que je
rencontre je parle que de jean-jacques
alors il en a ras-le-bol vous êtes
jamais dit celui-là je me le fais mais
non je suis pas comme ça ouais ouais
attendait avant que
là il faut des pressions jai vol il faut
c'est très compliqué ça se passe pas
comme ça va faire avoir des des moments
tendres en regardant quelqu'un qui
m'attendrait que aller tout de suite
dans un lit non il reste pas non mais
quand même ça s'est terminé ça fait 40
ans que j'étais alors c'est mon
éternelle fiancée pendant 40 ans elle et
moi je connais pas je peux pas le croire
c'est pendant ces quarante ans je ne
connais pas encore je ne connais pas
encore et c'est mon éternelle fiancée je
n'arrêterai pas de le dire
et puis je suis pas quelqu'un de neuf ne
fait pas venir et que vous avez envie
d'y croire tiré une fois merci alain
c'est vrai non mais moi j'en chaque je
pense que notre histoire a toujours
durer parce que durera pas ce que je
vais toujours de laisser sa liberté de
cécile aime bien sortir voir des copains
se délieront de borei débouchèrent
madame c'est un renouveau ça change à
chaque fois j'ai fait toute ma liberté
d'abord il ya jamais en tournée parce
qu'il a pas voyagé il a très peur dans
l'avion il est sans mal j'ai fait les
malins
j'ai fait le monde entier elle a bien
verrouillé
troisième le vertige les forces et de
bouffe équilibre dans ma tête
et puis moi moi je vous dis une chose si
je suis tellement fier que je me connais
je deviendrai championne de chistera ça
devait arriver
ouais la claque et puis on fait des
réunions sommet et puis chacun
s'explique et puis ça va pas je prends
ta valise je m'en vais mais là ça fait
40 ans que ça dure ben oui faut bien que
le corps exulte qu'on met le corps et sa
jaguar
ça n'empêche pas que on peut très bien
ça doré et faire comme tout le monde je
vais te placer des générations mais
justement c'est ça qui est bien c'est
que comme on est souvent séparés en rond
se revoient et on s'adore d'accord parce
que si on est tout le temps collée où
vas-tu qu'elle voulait serrer on n'a
jamais mis d'alliance enfin je reste à
l'antenne des enfants sa fille manon
sort du lot désert maintenant non non
mais l'alliance que j'avais j'ai c'était
un rideau allait doubler les alliances
se servir de leçon c'est non mais
qu'oublie les aliments c'est le mot qui
séparent sa fille comme elle aurait dû
séparé le premier jour mais jamais
interview
chantal goya est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je lui mets une grosse
patate
je crois que le prochain je vais le
faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu de
la vérité
j'ai fait un sit in au temps j'ai
inventé reality show est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit si je retrouve cette
[ __ ] d'institutrice je lui défense la
gueule est ce que vous êtes déjà dit bon
j'aime pas les enfants mais tant pis on
les adore est ce que vous êtes déjà dit
il boit d'accord mais bon il fait de
bonnes chansons quand même il n'est pas
alcoolique jean jacques et moi parce
qu'il aime le bon vin
mais il voit jamais le matin jamais à
midi et si je dîne avec lui le soir il
boit pas il est génial mais ce serait
incroyable vous êtes déjà d'y aller
après tout mon mec est en prison non
j'étais au bout de ma rue en plus vous
êtes déjà dit il est quand même bien
gaulée le capitaine flam non le vrai moi
c'était vous êtes déjà dit non 5 dans un
seul lycée trop puis ça fait quand même
coup y'a pas de mathématiques service
j'ai déjà dit chanteuse sait peut-être
pas mon truc
finalement ça l'ex fois parce que c est
parti pour être chanteuse et ça se voit
non mais je sais moi même parce que
j'aimerais bien chanter un peu mieux
vous êtes déjà dit j'ai envie de mourir
là oui je peux mourir mais mal grandes
antilles c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
de moi parce que les chansons non ce
matin ce mal est décédé constat n'est
pas m que tout le monde disait maurice
qu'on va la mettre
c'était une horreur j'ai déjà dit allez
hop ma grosse au régime oui oui quand
parce qu'il ya trois ans bien ici j'ai
essayé une robe et la vendeuse elle m'a
dit vous inquiétez pas quand vous aurez
fait votre bébé ça ira vous ira mieux
mais non c'est mon bide alors donc
région talons rentrer dare midi mais
décontracté vous vous êtes déjà dit et
si je me faisais refaire les seins non
non pas du tout ils vont très bien
au moins un essai
non non et non je ne vais pas tu fais
pas l'eau c'est à moi aimons bien vous
êtes déjà dit [ __ ] mais qu'est ce que
je fous queen à trois heures du matin
avec tous ces connards en train de
chanter ma passion pas tous ces connards
mais des fois je me dis il est 4 heures
du matin j'ai toujours pas chanter ils
sont tous comme des fous j'ai payé une
balle je donnerai pas là je commence à
m'endormir valoir que ça va être
catastrophique
et ben non j'ai la pêche et gilles fonds
papa ballon à trente deux ans à vous ça
vous fait pas flipper ça ou pas du tout
ces masses et non ça veut dire que je
suis leur père de leur enfant c'est ça
me fait un beau cadeau mais tu nous as
vu tout à l'heure
oui remarque chantal goya l'onac c'est
d'éviter chez jacques marie laffont
éditeur
[Musique]